30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
you on the App Store or Google Play
today's workout is a chair workout and
look who I have here mama
so this chair workout is really great
for those of you who might have lower
body injuries and you want to get back
into your fitness routine or for anybody
who wants to kick-start their fitness
journey let's begin we will not be
getting off this chair throughout the
entire workout yes but I'm going to make
sure that you have an awesome workout
and you will be sweating so it will be a
40 seconds workout with 20 seconds rest
in between
are you ready mom okay so let's start
with a gentle torso rotation just to
warm up the body slightly okay so just
left to right left to right I want you
to start to engage your core as we twist
okay so remember throughout the entire
workout I want you to sit right up do
not hunched over this is wrong making
sure that your posture is right and just
sit right at the edge of the chair okay
so the first workout is going to be
chair March alright you do not need any
weights at all so just gently place your
hands close to your body and I want to
imagine you're matching while standing
up okay so just gently tap the floor and
raise your legs and knees up okay the
higher you can go the better alright so
for those of you who might just get
started just start low as you progress
bring your knee up higher okay
mom are you doing okay the keep going
just relax your shoulders and just relax
your arms we're working on your legs and
also engaging the core okay remember to
sit up right throughout the workout
you keep marching and now just take a
twenty seconds rest okay so again do not
lean back always keeping your body
upright the next workout is to engage
your core
so knee to elbow place both hands just
close to your head okay
I want you to reach your opposite elbow
to the opposite knee
so tap and tap good that's it so just
gentle as much as you can reach your
elbow to your knee for those of you who
want more challenge what you can do is
raise both legs up and just reach okay
my mom is doing the modified version if
you want more challenge than follow me
good so both legs straight elbow to knee
very good do you feel your core working
nice keep going we're not stopping right
now only 40 seconds of work nice so
twist rotate feel your obliques one last
one and very good place both legs down
now let's grab some weights okay
so I have a pair of light dumbbells for
you who do not have any dumbbells follow
what my mom is doing grab two bottles of
water okay any weight of your choice
okay so the first workout is going to be
a front up to side rates and back down
working on your shoulders again front to
side and back down that's it okay up
open down good so up open very good good
job keeping again your chest up and your
back flat keep going your side back down
okay let's go front raise up side and
back down okay careful not to jerk up
side and back down nice keep it in a
smooth motion side and back down very
good still holding onto your dumbbells
we are still working on your shoulders
okay the next workout is al rotation so
lift the dumbbells all whatever bottle
you have up
making sure that both arms are in 90
degrees you want to make sure that your
arms are in line okay so do not drop it
down lift it up and all the way to do is
rotate it that's it and now let's rotate
back down that's it
keeping it in a 90 degree position up
and down so by keeping your arms up
throughout the entire workout you are
really engaged and work on your
shoulders up and down to your shoulders
nice do not drop right now you're
halfway there
rotate it back down again up and down
good mom doing well you're you showed us
are you sweaty I can see her sweating up
and back down
taught you this is a chair workout but
it's not going to be easy nice okay now
drop it back down we're still working
using the dumbbells okay see the chest
press again always make sure that your
starting position is in a 90 degree
angle what I want you to do is drive
both hands forward squeeze it squeeze
your chest bring it back good squeeze it
bring it back and nice so as you bring
the dumbbells forward squeeze your chest
okay bring it back whew I can really
feel my shoulders and my chest working
and back good keeping your body upright
okay do not hunch forward
up squeeze drive it back good and
squeeze and drive it back well who is
sweating let me know in the comments
below
push it forward my shoulders are burning
come on give me two more reps here okay
mom keep it going
one more rep and drive it back and just
drop the dumbbells okay and just gently
drop side to side very good okay so this
next workout is going to be a shoulder
press I want you to have both palms
facing in okay so both palms should be
facing in not out but in so it's really
simple just drive your weights up in a
straight line drive it back down close
to your
face drive it back up and back it down
okay once you're ready as you drive it
back up spread your legs and bring it in
ready mom let's go open good and in nice
up and in good so pointy toes and back
in good show the press with wide legs
spread and in drink good job so we're
working on your inner thighs and your
shoulders up in last two more good job
mom
you're doing well last one more out and
very good okay
the next two exercises will be focusing
on your back so still holding onto the
weights I want you to slowly then your
body forward okay from your hips do not
punch for the cake so keeping your back
straight chest up slowly bends forward
and bring both dumbbells close to your
side okay good so remember do not spread
your elbows drive it and squeeze your
mid-back very good gently gaze on the
floor nice up squeeze for one second
back down up good and back down good so
do not look straight ahead you will be
creating more tension on your neck so
down up good very good
and bring it up squeeze your mid-back
back down up and down
good give it two more last one and down
okay still maintaining in this position
let's work with reverse fly okay so with
both dumbbells by your side with the
palms facing in I want you to spread
your wings with the elbows slightly bent
drop it back down up spread your wings
good so this workout works more on your
upper back spread it drop it back down
up and down if you can try to bend lower
go lower good chest should be facing the
floor good
and down with any workouts do not jerk
okay
so nice and controlled movement good huh
I am sweating my mom is sweating but
we're feeling good keep going
squeeze it hold it for one count and
back down up hold it down good as you
progress you can always increase the
weights to challenge yourself even more
one last one and back down alright okay
final workout with the weights okay this
time we want to work on your core
muscles torso rotation okay so bring the
dumbbells together spread your elbows
out and all we want to do is to rotate
to your right and to your left okay
ready let's go right left right and left
okay so you're rotating your torso not
just moving your arms right to left
good nice keep going keeping your back
straight and get your core and keep
rotating good doing a good job if my mom
can do it you can do it too I love
working out with my mom just to give her
that extra motivation very good mom
alright last one okay good news drop the
dumbbells of your water bottle alright
okay so my mom will be doing the easier
modified version and I will be doing the
tougher version okay need to chat so sit
at the edge of your chair for beginners
what you can do is start with your right
and left okay let's go ma'am
up right and left good keep going good
for those of you who want more challenge
lift both legs up in out in and out so
you're supporting your upper body using
your hands okay and get your car you
should feel the work on your lower abs
as well as your upper abs good to drive
both knees
close your chest and extend it straight
out and in good keep going five more
seconds keep going good lift as high as
you can one more and back done okay
still working on your car we are not
done okay still working in your car
let's focus on your lower abs okay so
sit at the edge of your chair lick kicks
okay I want you to just gently tap if
you can mom keep tapping for those of
you again if you want more challenge
let's go lift both legs up and just
imagine you're doing flutter kicks keep
going nice so again do not hunch forward
okay keep your back straight chest up
and just flutter away good so if you
want a modified version you can follow
what mama is doing and just tap your
feet on the ground
nice come on guys do not stop right now
you have ten seconds left
oh I can feel the burn keep going last
five seconds you are strong and last one
seconds and just place both legs on the
floor okay nice easy hamstring stretch
so again straighten both legs toes
pointed forward hands just by your head
I just wait to burn from your hips with
a back straight to stretch your
hamstrings okay if you need to bend your
knees slightly just like my mom that's
fine okay so keeping a back straight
bend forward look down and feel the
stretch on your hamstrings and the work
on your lower back nice keep going down
and up good this is your final workout
and you will be getting a one-minute
rest
I know my mom needs that rest okay keep
going down and up down and up
who and take this time to just breathe
last one more feel the stretch in the
hamstrings and back up very very good so
one minute rest wipe your sweat keep
yourself hydrated breathe in and out
bring your heart rate down and we want
to repeat the entire workout once more
okay
[Music]
mom you okay give me a high five
awesome job and guess what we have one
more round okay so if you are doing this
from the comfort of your own home I want
you to challenge yourself for this
second set if you want to lift heavier
or do the tougher version okay all right
so let's start with the first workout
chair much just place both feet firmly
on the floor okay and let's start by
marching up down quema let's go she
needs a little bit of coordination but
she's doing great
all right let's go much only 20 seconds
so again I want you to keep your upper
body relaxed just really drive your
knees up and down okay do not think so
much just bring your knees up and down
and you've got this move good swing your
hands side to side front and back very
good
relax the shoulders and just tap nice
ten more seconds second circuit and I
want to see a stronger you keep going
and just rest it out okay let's work a
little bit on your course so me to elbow
remember this workout right elbow to
left knee let's go right elbow to left
knee good left elbow to right knee good
okay so this is the modified version and
if you want to challenge yourself lift
both legs up ready mom let's go up good
twist it and twist
point your toes forward okay very good
you should feel the work on your
obliques twist as far as you can reach
okay good keeping your shoulders spread
very good halfway there whoo breathe in
and out pace your breathing keep going
last ten more seconds if you can't reach
your elbow to your knees that's fine
okay keyboard
on this and you will only progress good
and just drop it right let's grab the
weights okay the first few exercises
will be working on your shoulders so
this is my favorite workout I love to do
this even in the gym so let's start with
front to side race okay
pumps facing it down ready let's go up
front race open up to your side and drop
good again front up side and drop very
good up side and drop because your
shoulders are small muscles you don't
have to lift too heavy okay so make sure
the dumbest are in line with your eyes
not too high and drop it back down so
just in line with your eyes good and
back it down working on your front your
side shoulders and back down again front
shoulders side shoulders and down whoop
up side and down last one up side and
back down
okay next L rotation remember we want to
always keep this 90 degree angle okay so
all you have to do is bring and rotate
up with the pumps facing forward and now
rotate with the pumps facing down
that's it let's go pumps facing forward
palms facing down okay and back it down
good this workout you know it really
burns my shoulders no matter how many
times or how light I lived if you want
to you can even do this without any
weights back down and back up okay very
good
working on our shoulders from all
different angles and down up and reach
hit it down good last few more we're
over there and the next one is a really
fun workout up
down last one up and done good okay this
is my favorite show the press with white
step okay so bring both dumbbells up
with the pumps facing forward remember
we're going press weight step and in
okay you got this okay
two more seconds ready let's go up and
in just like a dance good and in go out
and in a very good up up and in good
press it up and for your inner thigh
stretch out press it up bring it up as
close to your face and back in good so
do not drop the dumbbells too low okay
out and in very good let's keep going
you should also feel the work on your
outer glutes in a few more last one more
out and in come on one more for good
luck and done very good okay
next workout we'll be working on your
chest and your shoulders again
maintaining this 90 degree position we
want to work on seated chest press okay
so drive both dumbbells forward and
bring it back maintaining the 90 degree
position and drive it forward so the
dumbbells should be in line with your
chest not too hi mum lower down very
good there you go in line with your
chest and drive it back do not jerk
control the movement okay and press good
so keeping the dumbbells up throughout
the entire workout will really work on
your shoulders in and press making sure
that you're conscious
both arms are in a ninety degree
position keep going
press it back drive it forward back
that's two more okay I can feel my
shoulders burning last one more forward
and down okay for the next two workouts
we want to work on our back muscles okay
so sit right at the edge of your chair
and now
to just bend forward from your hips
keeping your chest up and your back flat
alright I wanted to drive both dumbbells
close to your side and drop it back up
back down and up okay keep your elbows
close do not spread your elbow good
there you go squeeze your back muscles
and down hold it for two counts and back
down good remember with any workout you
want to control the movements okay do
not just rush through because rushing
through the workouts means you will not
be engaging your muscles up back down
squeeze do not spread your elbows keep
your elbows close to your body
last one more and just rest it out okay
let's maintain the low position both
dumbbells spread your wings okay it's
time to fly okay let's go with the
elbows pointed back spread your wings
and bring it back down good so squeeze
your upper back bring it back down holy
for one count back down good really
engage feel back and back down okay so
bring your elbows as high up as you can
up and down good keep going let's go up
and down do not lock your elbows okay
always keeping a slight bent on your
elbows back down try bending forward
more to really engage your back up and
down good job you have five seconds left
that means two more repetitions up down
last one more up and done okay all right
now let's work on your core torso
rotation okay so you can choose to do
this workout without any weights or if
you want to lift the width up place them
close together spread your elbows okay
and now let's twist your right twist
your left
and right and left it is that simple
again we're working on the oblique
muscles twist good all right keep going
very good remember you're not just
moving your hands side to side okay
you're twisting your torso good last few
more doing okay mom you're almost at the
end of your workout okay so it is not
time to stop right now
few more and good news
drop your dumbbells let's place your
dumbbells down okay still working on
your core muscles knee to chest okay if
you want an easier version you can just
get bring one knee up and back down okay
just like my mom okay let's go on it's
not like to stop it mom what are you
doing keep going okay let's go challenge
yourself both legs up down up and down
okay keep going oh I love my mom look at
her she's challenging yourself if you
want to you can do that to both legs up
tap on the floor and up good very good
whew your lower abs and your upper abs
as well good keep going breathe in and
breathe out okay let's go last few more
point your toes point it keep a leg
straight last one more and just place it
down okay leg kicks again for an easier
version tap on the floor okay tap your
toes on the floor very good for a
tougher version
let's lift both legs up and let's go
flutter good job okay forty seconds
starts right now let's not stop right
now
end though you don't have to go too wide
okay keep the movement small but really
engage your lower abs alright this part
right here really engage your lower abs
keep your body upright chest up and you
are halfway there keep going doing good
making sure you're leaning back a little
bit okay
not too much ten seconds left oh yeah we
are strong and you have one final easy
workout after this and one more and rest
it out okay all right final hamstring
stretch okay
so keeping both legs straight with your
toes pointed forward sit at the edge of
a chair hands up okay by your head and
all I want you to do is keeping your
back flat bent frame your hips feel the
stretch in the hamstring up feel your
lower back back down and up okay do not
jerk if you jerk you will be causing
more injuries to your lower back so
control and up very good only go as far
down as you can okay if you need to bend
a knee slightly that is fine work on
your own flexibility back down and up
back down and up take this time to bring
your heart rate down and we want to end
with some gentle stretches okay very
very very well done that was two seconds
high-five month before we go let's end
this workout with some really gentle
stretches okay so what I want to do is
place your right leg on top of your left
leg and I want you just reach down
alright as far down as you can you don't
have to worry if you can't touch to the
floor okay what I'm ready to do is feel
the stretch on your glutes your right
glute okay
good very good again do not hunch what
keep your back straight and just gently
reach as far as you can for this
you the stretch on your glutes breathe
in and breathe out all right now let's
swap now left leg up okay same thing
reach only as far as you can okay we're
not in competition with anybody reach
and when when it comes to stretching it
is very important that you take a slow
inhale and slow exhale and just bring
your heart rate back down all right good
okay remember your shoulder press with
white legs now let's go white okay with
the toes pointed out and now let's just
stretch down reach down and feel your
inner thighs okay
again if you need to bend your knees
feel free to bend your knees if not then
point your toes out and really feel and
stretch out your inner thighs good very
good
just hold this position doing great
and now let's slowly come back up bring
your licks together now let's stretch
our upper body so show the stretch right
hand across and just pull it gently
stretching out your right shoulders good
and now left side down stretch it out
very good okay now I want you to
interlace both your fingers together
okay
cross it over there you go and now just
stretch forward punch it a little bit
and feel the stretch on your back okay
very good and again take a slow and long
inhale and a slow and long exhale all
right good now let's stretch out your
obliques so just grip onto the side of
each hair and just push and twist that's
it okay do not shift your body so your
knees should be pointed forward twist
and again the other side grab onto the
chair and just twist
all right and now both hands together
okay final stretch just gently torso
rotation to your left and to your right
do not bounce okay gently twisting and
now shoulder rotation back shoulder
rotation now let's go forward mom let's
go forward very good and now give
yourself a big clap she's excited I know
she's feeling good very very well done
okay you can do this from the comfort of
your own home I truly believe that
Fitness starts from home to kick that
your fitness journey with this video and
of course you can combine this workout
with my other workout videos do also
check out my meal plans my healthy
recipes fitness motivational videos and
more on my youtube channel if you
haven't yet subscribed you know what to
do hit the subscribe button and turn on
your notification button so that you
would get notified every time I upload a
new video
awesome job all the best and I will see
you in my next video